you know these uh uh
conspiracies you read about okay and you
know i don't know if you're into
conspiracies or not a lot of people are
as a ci agent i'm sure you're not but uh
you know some of these conspiracies like
who
who are some of the names that are
dropped that
world leaders that were you know working
for the cia because you know on the mob
you'll read this boss was working
closely with the fbi and nobody knew
about it for 15 years
he was this and he was dropping all the
information and i'm not even talking
about like a joe piston
you know who was actually working for
the fbi that went in for five years and
10 months i'm talking about like
actual world leaders that was donnie
brasco was it yeah i'm not talking about
nebraska i'm talking about guys that
were world leaders
who some say
the cia had them in their pockets and
they were giving them information who
were some of the names
you know what um
well vladimir putin um
he'd be one of them no i'm kidding
i'm just kidding everybody's wide open
on the table
yeah
he's secretly gonna destroy this that
was good i gotta give it to you that was
really good mike
mike's got a little bit of acting you
know and comedy yeah um
you know it's it's
there's been
that's a really good question because in
terms of world leaders normally the
question is like you know were there
celebrities were there you know
people that that had worked because they
were in the public eye but they could
travel everywhere and had access you
know from a world leader perspective
that's not really
that's not a target when you're talking
about a collection target if you're
looking to recruit uh access to a
country
your your first
landing spot is not the the leader right
i mean maybe there's relationships that
exist
um
as that person was coming up through the
ranks or whatever and eventually became
a leader and so you're going to you're
going to want to know what that's all
about you want to know whether you've
got anybody who went to school with them
or did whatever and that's that could
provide you with some insight but really
you're looking for people who have
actionable intelligence uh at sort of a
granular level so i you know i would
rather have rather than the world leader
sure it'd be nice to have them in their
pocket but um
you know you want that the guy who's
running a desk you know for a priority
target in some other intel service
overseas right i mean you're looking
that's what that's what you're looking
to do or you're looking for the the
deputy assistant uh foreign minister
right who's got terrific access but is
right there in decision-making you know
points
that's the sort of thing or you know
what you want the uh the housekeeper you
know for the uh for the world leader um
you want proximity but you know number
one is what you're saying how do you how
do you recruit what's the method of
recruiting folks like that
uh you know it's it's usually not
ideology right um it's usually a little
bit more based than that um
so you're talking you know possibly
money maybe you're talking about
you know you you
bump across some guy that's it's working
and your indications are maybe their gru
for instance or they're you know they're
fsb or whatever and you think uh that'd
be a good target and so you know maybe
you find out they got a couple of young
kids um and that's their i don't say
their weak link but that's really what
drives them you know and that a lot of
times that's what it is maybe their kids
sick maybe they need some medical
attention right or some assistance
that's simple yeah
it can be that simple um it could be
that oftentimes it not often but another
scenario is that they're just not
getting enough hugs from their home
service right or from wherever they're
not feeling the love they're not feeling
the love they feel like they're
disrespected nobody's listening to me
i'm too smart for this place and so now
suddenly you're providing an outlet for
them and now they feel important because
now they're getting that information to
somebody right and and it sounds odd
right it sounds like who's going to
[ __ ] going to betray their country and
their family and their government their
you know but
you know that sometimes can be a very
powerful thing right and that's
unfortunately in the counter
intelligence world when we talk about
people like hanson right and jim
nicholson or some of these guys edlie
howard that's pretty much what it was
they just didn't feel like they were
respected they were too smart for their
own place when the cia sets their sights
on somebody and says we want to get this
target i assume that's how it works like
this is the person we want
it's driven by it's driven by tasking so
it's driven by like okay we we need to
know exactly to the degree we can what
the
you know chinese military is spending
their money on you know in the next you
know
two years or three years are they
dumping all their money into hypersonics
or whatever so yeah you know be nice to
get somebody in the pla or whatever and
so
it's driven by the tasking and then you
start looking at who's got that who's
got access to that information and who
may be minded to talk to you who could
you actually access who could you get to
so there's a process that you go through
and to be fair most intel services go
through the same process because it's a
human thing and when they get
this target or this mission
how hard is it for that person to say no
meaning how much do you squeeze this
person to say
i'm not saying you do but i mean i gotta
imagine if you set your sights on
somebody and that's your target you're
not going to take no for an answer no no
it's i see what you say but it doesn't
work that way because
you you never want to coerce somebody
into this right you you don't want to
because that's a that's a bad route it's
like with blackmail people always think
uh you're gonna you know you're gonna
you know hook them because they they've
compromised themselves well
maybe but and this is somewhat nuanced
if someone compromised itself they do go
out there and they do something that
they as if say they're an intel uh
you know officer for some foreign
country that's a target for us
uh if they compromise themselves they do
something they shouldn't have done
you're not necessarily using that right
as as the hook what you're doing is
you're saying okay there's a weakness
there right there's a the
that's that's the weakness now we're
going to build around that right because
you know hooking somebody up by
blackmail or or strong-arming them
then it just it just doesn't work their
heart needs to be in it essentially well
they need to feel that they're they're
doing the right thing right and they're
doing it for the right reason even if
they're complete you know [ __ ] and
you know and
you know it's just
why'd you look at tom when you said that
he doesn't appreciate that there we go
even if they're a complete [ __ ] i
mean so
yeah i mean there you go so there's a
reason we're opposite that
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]
you